What do you think of when you hear the word
"vacation?" Perhaps you imagine lying by a beach,
watching the sunset over the clear blue
water, feeling the sand between your toes,
a tropical drink in your hand. Perhaps you see
yourself in a cozy log cabin in the woods, snow
gently falling outside, a roaring fire warming
your feet while you catch up on your reading.
Or maybe you think of a luxurious spa, seaweed
wraps, natural hot springs, and cucumber slices
on your eyes. But what about those of us who are
sick of the usual getaways on offer, who want to
take a trip that not only shakes up their routine,
but their sense of reality as they once knew it?
Here at Marshall, Carter, and Dark, we strive
to provide vacation experiences for the more
discerning traveler. The more, shall we
say, adventurous. Someone who's had enough
of those white sand beaches in the Caribbean,
who's sick of villas in the South of France,
and wants to invest their hard-earned
money in a destination that is completely
and utterly unique. We've curated a selection
of potential vacation destinations to choose
from for just that sort of customer, someone with
an adventurous spirit and money to burn. From the
mind-bendingly surreal to the downright dangerous,
we promise that a trip to one of our prestige
vacation spots will help you make memories you
won't soon forget- no matter how hard you try.
Most of our usual clientele wouldn't dream of
furnishing their home with items from an Ikea,
but don't let that stop you from considering the
first destination in our catalog! SCP-3008, also
known as the Infinite Ikea, is less of a retail
store and more of an all-inclusive experience. It
looks like an ordinary Ikea from the outside, but
inside? Well, that's a different story altogether.
Once you've passed through the main entrance
to the building, the possibilities are
literally endless, as the interior extends to an
infinite size defying all known laws of physics!
You'll find a variety of accommodations,
from any furniture piece you can think of
to a wide array of Scandinavian culinary
delights. Just watch out for the faceless
entities in employee uniforms, and
don't let them catch you after dark!
Here's what Mary, 45, from Pennsylvania, had
to say about her stay in the Infinite Ikea:
"Please God, someone get me out of here! They took
my husband, and I'm getting so sick of meatballs!"
Are you something of a city slicker
looking for a country mouse experience?
Trying to get away from all the hustle
and bustle and just kick back and relax,
but also want to avoid going to the
same idyllic English villages that
all your friends at the country club have
already tried? Look no further than Temby,
a charming little hamlet in Oxfordshire,
England, with its own specialized, local
curse. You won't find this phenomenon anywhere
else, making for a truly exclusive experience.
Every twelve years, an invisible entity known as
The Crooked Man spends 70 days targeting random
individuals in the town's limits, corrupting
the shape of their house, tormenting them with
supernatural activity, and finally, twisting and
breaking their bones, stretching their limbs out
beyond recognition. But don't worry, as a new
visitor to the town, it's unlikely you'd be
picked. And even if you are, who doesn't like
coming home from a trip with a fresh new look?
Here's what Jim, 32 from New York
City, thought of his time in Temby:
"You can't imagine the things I've heard...the
things I've seen... Have you ever seen a
man whose legs bent in a dozen different
directions, so stretched out and deformed
he can't even stand up anymore? I have. The
worst part was when the screaming stopped,
when he got used to the feeling of stretching
and cracking, bones snapping over, and over,
and over again until he was something else.
I hear that sound at night just before I
fall asleep. I see him when I close
my eyes. I wish it had taken me too."
But maybe that isn't quite what you
have in mind. Maybe you're looking for a
more...permanent vacation. You've had quite
enough of the annoyances of everyday life,
of your neighbor's dog that just won't
stop barking at all hours of the night,
of the strangers standing too close to you in
line at Starbucks and breathing down your neck.
You just want to leave it all behind for good, and
finally get some peace and quiet. If this sounds
like you, then why not check out SCP-2935?
This space-time anomaly tucked away inside
of a limestone cave beneath a cemetery near
Joppa, Indiana contains the gateway to a world
identical to our own, with one exception: Every
single life form there is dead. From the birds
and the bees to the flowers and trees, to that
bartender that never makes your martini the way
you like it no matter how many times you explain
it to him, they're all gone. But keep in mind,
what happens in SCP-2935, stays in SCP-2935. By
which I mean, once you're there, you can't come
back. Otherwise, death will follow you into
our world, and we can't have that now can we?
I'd provide you with a testimony from a
satisfied customer who stayed in SCP-2935,
but every time I tried to get Eliza,
27, from Los Angeles on the phone,
it's all just static. So I guess
you'll have to take my word for it.
Maybe you're not just looking for a vacation
to help you get away from it all. Perhaps
you're looking for a chance to self-reflect. Well,
there is no better place for that than SCP-1919,
or the Hotel of Duplicates. It's an
early 20th-century hotel and converted
mansion located at an undisclosed location -
address will be provided to you upon booking.
On the outside, it's in mostly pristine condition,
but looks can be deceiving. The inside is
dilapidated and rotten, covered in water
damage. When you enter the hotel, doppelgangers
of you will manifest throughout the building,
looking exactly like you with a few notable
differences. Maybe they'll be missing their eyes,
or have unnaturally long arms or large jaws.
Whatever the case may be, all of these mirror
images will become aggressive, attempting to
destroy you by any means necessary. You can
either succumb to the attacks of your infinite
doubles, or somehow escape with your life.
Talk about a way to get the blood pumping! And,
by coming face to face with yourself and your
own flaws, you'll be able to leave the experience
with a new lease on life! If you survive, that is.
Roberto, 55, from Indianapolis, had a great time
at the Hotel of Duplicates!
Just listen to his testimony:
"No mirrors...please, cover the
mirrors. I can't look at it...can't
look at my face...there were so
many of them...so much blood..."
Up next is SCP-3001, or the Red Reality.
After so much time trapped in there,
Dr. Scranton needs some company! Just kidding,
of course. We may be ruled by the almighty
dollar, but we're not monsters. We'd never
subject a paying customer to horrors of the
Red Reality. Speaking of red places, though…
Kick back poolside with SCP-354, the red pool!
You probably will want to swap out your swimsuit
for a down coat, because it gets pretty cold up
in the wilderness of Northern Canada, but hey,
a pool is a pool! This pool is filled, not with
chlorinated water, but a thick red liquid similar
to human blood. Don't worry though, it's not
actually blood! That would be ridiculous.
It's just a mysterious liquid of an unknown
origin, filling a pool that has no discernible
bottom. Every so often, creatures will emerge from
the pool and attempt to attack anything they see.
Who needs a trip to the zoo, when the animals
can come to you? You might encounter giant bats,
a levitating black sphere that emits directed
beams of radiation, an unknown abomination covered
in tentacles, or something else you can't even
imagine! So pour a drink, kick off your shoes,
and maybe keep a weapon at the ready as you
lounge by the side of the picturesque red pool.
Brandy, 24, from Chicago, had a
fantastic time at the red pool!
"This is Mochi, she's my cloud cat! Yeah, a cat
made out of water vapor. She came out of the pool,
and I gave her some tuna sashimi, and now she's
my best friend! Don't get too close though,
she's not into most humans, she'll
take your skin right off! Good kitty."
Pip pip cheerio, jolly ol' London town,
innit? Have you always wanted to go to London,
but find it just a bit too mainstream? Well, what
if there was a place you could visit that's just
like London, but not quite? Well, I've got great
news for you, person with incredibly specific
tastes. SCP-1678, or UnLondon, is a full-scale
mirror image of London, located one kilometer
beneath the city itself. It's a truly underground
spot. If you're a fan of the vintage look,
then that's even better! UnLondon is modeled after
the city as it appeared in the Victorian era, with
gas lighting on the streets instead of electric,
and architecture reflecting that time period.
UnLondon was constructed for human
habitation after an apocalyptic scenario,
so make yourself comfortable! Take
a nap in a military-grade bunk bed,
wander around the Natural History
Museum's "Fall of Man" exhibit,
and savor a nice bowl of Dr. Goody’s Wonderfood!
Just be on the lookout for the Bobbies,
mechanized corpses fashioned into makeshift police
officers. They don't take kindly to trespassers!
But don't take my word for it,
listen to Chuck, 44, from Boston!
"UnLondon was wonderful. I love consuming
the nutrients found in Dr. Goody’s
Wonderfood, it provides me with everything my body
needs. I'm not frightened of the Bobbies anymore,
I'm a good citizen. I do not fear the Eyes in the
Sky and I do not pity the Wretches. They pay the
price for their betrayals and will pay it the rest
of their days. The trip was worth the scurvy."
Sometimes you want to get out of civilization
and spend some time reconnecting with nature,
getting back to your roots. If you want to
go to a place where nobody knows your name,
and nobody should ever find out what
it is, then may I recommend SCP-4000?
I can't tell you too many details about it, you'll
have to see its unique charms for yourself, but
it's a forest that can be entered if you complete
the proper ritual, emerge from a well, and walk
down a path to your destination. There are a
few strict rules you'll need to follow during
your stay among the anomalous creatures that dwell
there: Don't call anything by a consistent name.
Don't answer to a consistent name. Always accept
gifts, but do not consume them. And finally:
if a ghost tells you it isn't a creature, obey
it. Don't let all the rules scare you though,
the beings in this enchanted forest
make for some really Good Neighbors.
Just ask Barb-
"Shh! Don't say my name! Never say my name.
If you do, they'll take it. And once my name
is gone...the rest of me follows. Don't
go into the forest, it's not worth it.
Don't dance with them, no matter how sweetly they
ask. And don't eat what they give you! Never,
ever eat it. It's like the old poem
says, 'we must not look at goblin men,
we must not buy their fruits, who knows upon
what soil they fed their hungry thirsty roots."
I know I said that these were all vacation spots,
but have you ever considered finding a new home
instead? Somewhere you can put down roots and
really build a community? The people of SCP-599
are always looking for new neighbors, after
all. It's a small city located in an undisclosed
location, earning it the nickname, Uncharted
City. Don't be dissuaded by the fact that everyone
living in the town matches the description of
someone who went missing in a different, inferior
town. This is a perfectly nice place to live,
and once you visit, you'll never want to leave.
Just ask Mario, 65, from Virginia!
"You really should think about purchasing
a house here, it's such a lovely place to
raise a family. Just come and stay the night,
you'll see. This place was made for you."
Picture this, if you will: You're staying
the night in a luxurious Victorian mansion,
and it's a dark and stormy night. A clap
of thunder shakes you from your slumber,
and a flash of lightning illuminates the
bedroom where you sleep. Your heart leaps
into your throat as you think you see someone
standing at the foot of your bed. You light
a candle to check, but no. It's just a
chair with a coat slung over the back.
You're alone. Just you, the enormous, empty house,
and the sound of rain pitter-pattering against the
window. You can't relax, though, can't get your
mind to slip back into the blissful escape of
sleep. You feel as if the walls are closing
in on you, as if the room is getting smaller
and smaller, enveloping you in darkness. You
take your candle and use it to light the way
as you slowly open the door to the bedroom with
an eerie creek. Then, you step out into the hall.
What was that sound?
That soft sigh, the padding of footsteps, coming
from over there. You turn, shining the flickering
light of the flame in the direction of the noise,
and see the figure of a woman in a long, flowing
dress. She's beautiful, or she would be if she
looked alive. Instead, she's pale, translucent,
her wide dark eyes staring into your very soul.
You can smell the scent of rotting plumeria
flowers, the salt and iron of tears and blood.
Slowy, she begins to drift toward you. Not walk,
but float, as her feet never touch the ground.
You open your mouth to scream, but no sound
comes out. She reaches her ghostly fingers out
to brush your cheek, and everything goes black.
Doesn't that sound like a one-of-a-kind
experience? Don't be scared, that was no
malicious spirit, it was just the lady of the
house! Clara Rosyth may not be the best hostess,
but her home is lovely, a stately mansion
located in Dark Peak in Derbyshire,
England. Sure, it's a little haunted. But
all of the best historical houses are.
Daphne, 42, from London, had
this to say about her stay there:
"So cold...so cold...Check the children,
please? You have to check the children!"
Settle down, Daphne. Go back
to bed. Now, where was I?
Now maybe you don't want to be confined to
the space within the walls of a haunted house,
or any house, for that matter. So how about
we get back to nature with a nice, simple,
lakeside camping trip? Just set up your
tent at least 50 meters away from the water,
and take in the crisp fresh air and wonderful
view. Feel the breeze rolling in off of the lake,
and...oh what's that? Do you see something,
floating in the water? It's alright,
it's just SCP-2316. If you look for a
while, it might start to look familiar.
Right, Chris from Iowa?
"I recognize them. The bodies,
in the water. I know them. My
friends...I'm so sorry. I have
to go. I have to go to them..."
Alright, buddy, you do that. Anyway, if you
do decide to visit SCP-2316, try and remember:
You do not recognize the bodies in the water. And
maybe don't take a dip in that particular lake.
You've heard about Christmas in December,
and even Christmas in July, but how would
you like to visit a place where it's Christmas
all year round, and the holiday fun never stops?
If that sounds like heaven on earth to you, then
you'll be a perfect fit for SCP-784, Christmas
Cheer. This quaint little neighborhood in Texas
doesn't have much to offer in terms of sights,
with only twenty-four houses and two apartment
buildings, but the atmosphere more than makes up
for it. No matter what time of year you visit,
the town will always be covered in a layer of
freshly fallen snow, and every building is wrapped
in Christmas lights at a density of fifteen lights
per square meter. And if you thought the decor
was charming, wait until you meet the residents!
Every person in SCP-784 is dressed in
their Holiday best, usually in novelty
Christmas sweaters emblazoned with smiling
reindeer, Santa Claus, glittering ornaments
and twinkling lights, and really just
about anything that screams "Christmas!"
During the day, the townspeople will decorate
their houses and exchange presents, as well as
putting on Christmas pageants and dances.
When night falls, they will share eggnog,
sing Christmas carols, and decorate any foreign
objects that might have made their way into the
town's vicinity. Just make sure that you
keep your Christmas Spirit at its best and
brightest while you're visiting, or you might
find yourself tied up with string lights and
dragged into the nearest house for a bit
of Yuletide Reprogramming. Whether you're
looking for a place to spend Christmas,
or just trying to inject a bit of extra
festivity into your everyday life, this is
the perfect place for your ho ho holiday!
Unfortunately, none of our
clients who've chosen this
destination will stop singing carols
long enough to provide testimony,
but just take that as a sign that their time in
this Christmas Village was truly life-changing.
Do you consider yourself something of a bookworm?
When your friends are going out to private clubs,
enjoying gourmet dinners, or headed
on early morning hikes on the beach,
do you prefer to stay in and crack open
your favorite novel? Then perhaps you'd
like to visit the best library in any known
universe. That's right, a book-lover's fantasy.
The Wanderer's Library is an interdimensional
library that acts as the embodiment of all
knowledge. Its ever-expanding collection of
literature includes every book ever written,
and some that haven't been written yet
in your native timeline! Wander the
endless stacks of books, take in the peaceful
environment, and study up on any subject your
heart desires. And if you're not prepared
to completely unplug, there's also wifi!
Professor Lisa Graham thoroughly enjoyed
her stay in the Wanderer's Library!
"I know a little bit of everything now.
I've looked into the past, the present,
the future...the greatest minds in the multiverse
at my fingertips. How am I supposed to
go back to a 9 to 5 job after that?!"
Now, we've covered quite a few places under the
jurisdiction of the SCP Foundation, but our final
offering is something quite exceptional: the
chance to stay at an official Foundation site.
The SCP Foundation's Site-19 is the perfect
getaway for a real Foundation enthusiast,
someone who's a massive fan of the work
they do and excited to see all of their
favorite anomalies and scientists.
Meet the famous Dr. Jack Bright! Just
don't touch that amulet. Say hello to
Dr. Gears before he shoos you away so
he can focus on his work. And do you like
anomalies? They've got them in spades here!
SCP-035, the Possessive Mask, glowers out from
its protective glass case. SCP-096 huddles in
the corner of its containment cell, hiding its
face. No peeking! Maybe you'll get to see SCP-049
performing one of his trademark experiments,
though if you're feeling under the weather,
you might not want to let him see you.
Maybe you want to sneak a look at SCP-173,
and see if you can catch it
snapping any D-Class necks!
Feel something nudging your foot? It's
just the friendly instances of SCP-131,
here to check things out and make sure you're
having a fantastic time. If you're tired,
get some rest in the employee sleeping
quarters. Hungry? Grab a bite at the canteen.
There's just so much to do
here at Foundation Site-19-
"Hey, you're not authorized to be in here!"
Just giving a tour, gentlemen,
I'll be finished in a moment.
"Sir, I'm going to have to ask you to leave.
If you don't comply, I'll have to use force."
Looks like that's my cue! All payments can be made
out to Marshall, Carter, and Dark! Think of us
when you book your next vacation! And remember:
Absolutely no refunds under any circumstances.
Now go check out “SCP-2521 and Infohazard
SCPs Explained” and “SCP-002 The Living
Room & the Most Terrifying SCP Rooms”
for more malevolent SCP rundowns!